it's a very important part of the poi
foo I want us to develop is the simple
idea of being able to move the arms in
opposite directions circling one arm
forwards and the other arm backwards and
learning to do this with a lot of
symmetry I'm also learning to do it in a
way that's healthy for the body and a
surprising amount of adults can't
circle one arm forwards and the other
backwards and we're rectifying this face
this way with me and let's turn in this
direction and take your right arm and
circle your right arm forwards now as
we're learning poi you're gonna always
have missed cultivating this sense of
these sort of invisible walls we'll call
it no that's what we call the wall plan
so you're circling your right arm
forwards along that invisible wall and
it can help a lot if you have a visual
reference like I've got a line here on
the dock so I can using kind of my
peripheral vision see whether my hands
really traveling along that line because
it's tendency as people might reach way
back here which isn't on the line
anymore so if you stand near a wall or
over a lawn your hip some kind of
reference that's gonna help right now I
also want you to notice I'm my whole
body's engaged I'm not standing and
torquing on my shoulder I'm opening my
body and that makes it quite easy on my
shoulder awesome even a few backwards as
well few forwards a few backwards yeah
and you're cultivating but ease just the
whole body where the shoulder stays
really relaxed and that feeling of like
you're mine and you're moving along that
wall take the left hand also you can do
some backward circles and again see how
there's movement right for my feet knees
hips waist shoulders everything's moving
so my body is really turning with the
arms and I'm imagining that wall I can
do some forwards
the next thing I want to do is simply
this face face me for a moment okay and
you're simply going to inhale the arms
from strap the sides so they're directly
above the shoulders exhale come back
down inhale that comes right up exhale
they come down okay inhale the cop
exhale they come down right now face
this way again
as you inhale your body's going to turn
away from you so your left shoulder is
going forward your right shoulders going
back and your hands raised together so
you pass your perfectiy and as you get
to the top you're facing forwards again
and your hands are directly above the
shoulders and as you exhale your right
hand sliding down the front your left
hand down the back and you end up here a
lot of people try to do all these funny
things in front not the arms going away
or just doing this that's why I showed
you that right the hands are not to miss
they're not doing this relative to your
body inhale
you're the top exhale you're at the
bottom hands are right on the thighs
inhale right above the shoulders exhale
to the thighs
this might take some cultivating it
might take some practice you might want
to do it up against the wall so you can
actually run at least in one of your
hands literally along the wall until you
can begin to breathe and relax with it
inhale exhale inhale exhale don't
hyperventilate so you can let go of the
inhales and exhales after a while and
eventually you'll just be circling one
forwards and one backwards what tends to
go wrong is people start to pass their
hands in front if you pass them in front
you'll try to do this and that won't
work
it's hard to bend your shoulders that
way so at the top they really need to go
right above the shoulders right above
the head and then at the bottom right
past the hips right over the top
and right past the hips once it begins
to work you can go the other way the
left goes forwards the right goes
backwards this is really deeply
programming some important things into
the body and it's only gonna come with
practice so come back to it a few times
over the course of the week until you
can Circle forwards if we write
backwards the left and forward with the
left backwards the right and as we
develop the muscle memory of all of this
will start to be able to add play and
eventually we'll be doing things like
this and all kinds of great fun movement
that really feel like flying but you
need to get into your body first or at
least that's why I like to take people
through this so just put time until you
feel like it's beginning to work and if
that doesn't make sense if you you know
you can always ask questions show me
what's going on I'm going to give you
more feedback
[Music]